The court deems defendants' use as
Ethan Klein's own case being used against him. And what is the
underlying message here? The underlying message is in fact that
citing Ethan Klein's case, we determine that snarking is your
right as an American. You have an American right enshrined in
American law to
>> We're about to read the Denims [music] docket. Okay,
the Denims sorry, Denims ruling, the ruling on the motion for
Motion for judgment? Motion for judgment, I think. Okay, from
Denims. Basically a most motion to dismiss that is tentatively
granted. That's their tentative decision going into a hearing
tomorrow. We're going to give that a quick look. Ten Entertainment
Inc. versus Denims et al. Hearing is June 5th, 2026 at 2:15 p.m.
So, that's tomorrow, 2:15 p.m. Western time. We should have a
good idea after that on what's going on. If both parties submit
on on the tentative
please advise the courtroom deputy here, and no appearance will
be required. So, if you already like agree with this, that's
fine. I would love to know when this was sent out to them. Cuz
I think Denims has basically said this is not anything yet, okay?
But I I think she's soft playing it cuz she doesn't want to celebrate
before she wins, to be honest with you.
I really do. The court is in receipt of defendants' motion for
judgment on the pleadings.
Docket number 35. The court hit heard oral arguments on June
5th, 2026. For the reasons explained herein, the court grants
the motion. This is a motion for judgment, which is functionally
equivalent to a most motion to dismiss. Plaintiff, Ten Entertainment
Inc., sued defendant,
Denims,
in docket number one since the initial complaint. Plaintiff brings
the following claims for relief. One, direct copyright infringement
against Denims, and two, contributory copyright infringement
against the H3 snark mods.
Plaintiff is production company that produces content for social
media, namely YouTube. Defendant is an online streamer who releases
content on social media platforms, namely Twitch. Plaintiff,
through its owner, YouTuber Ethan Klein, filed this action seeking
statutory damages against the defendant for her alleged livestream
reaction to plaintiff's tragicomedy tragicomic documentary entitled
Content Nuke Hasan [__] The Nuke, posted on plaintiff's
YouTube channel on January 31st, 2025.
The Nuke centered on the allegedly controversial political ideologies
of the alt-left Twitch streamer Hasan [__]
regarding the Israel-Palestine conflict.
The Nuke contains original footage, highly edited monta- highly
edited montages, par- parodic skits, and archival materials.
The film aims to expose how [__] radicalizes people
online to be anti-Semitic and anti-Israeli and criticizes Twitch
as a
>> Sorry, somebody sent me this picture.
Wait, what does it say?
Thus, the defendant's motion for judgment on pleadings is granted.
What?
>> We'll have to read through the whole thing, but Pisco
is validating my my claims, okay? Pisco, let's go.
Validating my claims that it is actually a win. Let's see. Let's
see.
Denims gets a win in the Ethan Ralph copyright case for The Nuke
claim. The court has held tentatively her reaction was fair use.
As I previewed weeks ago, if the court relied on Stepin's, Denims
would be in a good spot. Completely absent from analysis, intentional
stated malice. Dude, Pisco can't help himself, can't he? Pisco
literally can't help himself. He just goes, By the way, I was
totally right. By the way, just so you guys know, just in case
you were curious, I was totally right. You were all wrong. I
was right. I was right. I was right. You were wrong. You were
wrong. You were wrong. I was right. You.
that's what this line says, okay? All right, let's continue on
with this document. On January 27th, 2024, plaintiff submitted
its application to register the Nuke with the United States Copyright
Office, the USCO. On January 28th, 2025, the USCO received the
deposit copy of the Nuke. The registration number for the Nuke
is PAU well, whatever. Throughout defendant's livestream, defendant
provides commentary pertaining to the criticism of the Nuke.
Or to criticism of the Nuke. Indeed, plaintiff states where the
Nuke seeks to expose how [__] radicalizes people
online to be anti-Semitic and anti-Israeli, Denims attempts to
use the Nuke for the exact opposite purpose, to radicalize her
audience to be anti-Semitic and anti-Israeli along with defending
Hasan.
Wait. Wait, that can't be right.
Where the Nuke seeks to expose [__] Denims attempts
to use the Nuke for the exact opposite purpose, to radicalize
her audience to be anti-Semitic and anti-Israeli. [laughter]
Oh, wait. Hold on. No, that's his That's in the complaint. Sorry,
sorry, that's in the Plaintiff states that. Plaintiff states
that. Oh, hold on. That is the plaintiff stating that, but this
is the funny point. Hold on. No, no, no, no, no. This is the
funny point is that
that argument is being used to explain how it's so transformative.
Yes, this is the moment where he says, "Well, it actually is.
She's using it for the precise opposite purpose. It's like entirely
transformative, actually." Thank you, Ethan Klein. Thank you.
Hold on. Wait, there's more to the Pisco tweets. As I've always
maintained, I still think Ethan has a strong claim on their countdown
reaction, and therefore is likely to win on at least one of the
causes of action. But, the Nuke reaction by Denims was always
the harder case, especially when compared to other reactions,
cough XQC. This is tentative, yes, but given the language here,
hard for me to see Ethan recovering on the claim, except perhaps
on appeal if he so chooses. Wait, did Ethan actually file the
lawsuit on the other thing as well? Wait, did Ethan actually
file his lawsuit on both, the stream and Cuz the funny thing
about the stream is I actually don't know that she'll be hit
for for stream
in the same way, or I think given that it's filed in the same
stuff, reacting to a live stream as another live streamer, I
don't know that you would lose very much even if you get up and
walk away if it's like it would depend, but I I don't believe
that you should get the same level of payout.
Paragraph 70, during the live stream defendant contends that
the nuke resembles a high school video project or middle school
project. Live stream video here. Defendant also complains about
the documentary's editing, the sources, and the sources the documentary
relies upon and supposed inconsistencies of client statements,
and that the video treats the audience as morons as it allegedly
attempts to trick them. As further support of defendant's commentary
throughout the live stream, the complaint states that that defendant
frequently makes comments that are later contradicted by the
nuke itself. Complaint paragraph 70i. Defendant offers further
criticism of the subject documentary during her live stream,
see generally complaint Following one of the documented creator's
criticisms of Piker's apology of China's genocide of Uyghurs,
defendant comments on the treatment of Uyghurs, sorry. So much
of American media is focused on pointing out how evil China is.
Stating that disabled Americans lose disability benefits when
they get married, for incarceration levels in the US, live stream
videos here. Additionally, during the live stream defendant one
challenges client's perception of Piker's sentiments regarding
the interaction between imports and the fleeing of people from
Israel. Imports and the fleeing of people from Israel, okay.
Disputes client's account of the events of occurrence of violence
of hostages, critiques client's discussion of Twitch's enforcement
and moderation
Discus- and for discusses her perspectives on Zionism and Judaism.
After the pleadings are closed, but early enough not to delay
the trial, a party may move for judgment on the pleadings. A
motion for judgment on the pleadings under rule 12c is functionally
identical to a motion to dismiss under Federal Rules of Civil
Procedure 12b6.
And the principal difference is the time of the filing.
The same standard applies to motions brought under either rule.
Thus, the issue presented by a rule 12c motion is the same as
that posed in a rule 12b6 motion, whether the factual allegations
of the complaint state a plausible claim for relief.
When the plaintiff pleads factual content that allows the court
to draw the reasonable inference that the defendant is liable
for the misconduct
It was weird that Ethan Klein, like shouldn't he have been responding
or shouldn't there have been some response? Like him saying some
of these things, I feel like Denims was alleging things or saying
and Ethan Klein was not contesting them.
Judgment on the pleadings is proper when the moving party clearly
establishes on the face of the pleadings that no material issue
of fact remains to be resolved and that it is entitled to judgment
as a matter of law.
Okay. Analysis. Defendant moves for judgment on the pleadings
as to plaintiff's first claim for the relief of direct copyright
infringement as to the nuke based on the second affirmative
defense of fair use as played in the defendant's answer.
The motion for judgment. The fair use doctrine is an equitable
rule of reason that permits courts to avoid rigid application
of the copyright statute when on occasion it would stifle the
very creativity the law was designed to foster.
The fair use of copyrighted work for purposes such as criticism,
comment, news reporting, teaching, scholarship, or research is
not an infringement of copyright. The four non-exclusive factors
courts consider when determining fair use are: one, the purpose
and character of the use, including whether such use is of the
is of commercial nature or is for non-profit educational purposes.
Two, the nature of the copyrighted work. Three, the amount and
substantiality of the portion used in relation to the copyrighted
work as a whole. And four, the effect of the use upon the potential
market for or value of the copyrighted work.
Defendant moves for judgment on pleadings in part because of
the transformative nature of fair use. The first statutory factor
examines the purpose and character of the use, including whether
such a use is of a commercial nature or is for non-profit educational
purposes. This factor has taken on a heightened significance
because it influences the lens through which we consider two
other fair use factors. The central inquiry under the first factor
is whether the new work is
Transformative does not appear in this, but yet it permeates
copyright analysis. Transformative works add something new to
an existing work endowing the first with new expression, meaning,
or message rather than merely superseding the objects of the
original creation. Okay.
In contrast, oh, wait, wait, wait. We have a The court in Campbell
held that the central purpose of this investigation is to see
whether the new work merely supersedes the object of the original
creation or instead add something new with a further purpose
or different character altering the first with new expression,
meaning, or message. It asks, in other words, whether and to
what extent the new work is transformative. Now, Ethan Klein,
of course, basically conceded in his own response, I think. I
think it's his response to their opposition, that obviously Donna's
use was transformative. So, it's This is almost already immediately
accepted, okay? In contrast, commentary that has no critical
bearing on the substance or style of the original composition,
which the alleged infringer merely uses to get attention or to
avoid the drudgery in working up something fresh, the claim to
fairness in borrowing from another's work diminishes accordingly.
I would say this is Yeah, like I said, it's obviously critical.
It's obviously trying to do the opposite purpose. So, as admitted
by Ethan Klein, this is already given. The court deems defendant's
use as transformative.
Let's
The court deems defendant's use as
Notably, the fair use inquiry does not ask whether the criticism
or parody of the copyrighted work is just or accurate or mean-spirited,
but simply whether the use is the kind of that copyrighted copyright
is designed to protect.
Finding fair use where a copyrighted image of a model was posted
on a website with comments underneath including every time I
saw her, I thought she was super ugly and awkward-looking and
wondering how the model could get married to that rich guy and
be a model. Okay.
Someone got sued for that? That's crazy. Defendant offers other
criticism of the subject documentary during her live stream,
see the complaint.
Following one of the documentary creators criticisms of Piker's
apology of China's genocide of Uyghurs, defendant comments, "We've
already seen
This has already been gone over. Okay.
Additionally, during the live stream, defendant challenges client's
perception of Piker's sentiments regarding the interaction between
imports and the fleeing of the people from Israel or of the people
from Israel. Disputes client's accounts with of violence against
hostages, perspectives on Zionism. These are just reposted. Okay.
The court finds defendant's criticisms and commentary within
the live stream video to demonstrate the following telltale signs
of transformative use. One, further purpose or different character
in the defendant's work, i.e., the creation of new information,
new aesthetic, new insights or understanding. And two, the use
of quoted material matter as raw material instead of repackaging
it and merely superseding the objects of the original creation.
The undisputed purpose of defendant's live stream is to contest,
criticize, or mock plaintiff's message, which the courts have
found ways in favor of fair use due to its transformative nature.
See Hosenballah v. Klein.
So, hold on. The best part about this
Ethan Klein's own case being used against him. And what is the
underlying message here? The underlying message is in fact that
citing Ethan Klein's case, we determine that snarking is your
right as an American. You have an American right protected in
American law, enshrined in American law, to snark.
Snarking is a right.
Copyright, it is transformative. Snarking is transformative
as determined
by the US by the Southern District of New York in 2017
in the Hosenballah versus Klein case. Okay. This is the snarkiest
argument in legal history. It really is, isn't it?
Starking is legal.
Starking is legal. And trust me, with a lot of people threatening
to DMCA or threatening to abuse the copyright system recently,
it's good to have it reiterated that starking is legal.
Thank you very much to this California court for pointing this
out. Even if this judgment, by the way, even if this were to
be reversed, they they throw out new evidence or something. Even
if that were to be the case, okay?
Finding that the first factor weighed in defendant's favor as
the defendant's reaction video was quintessential criticism and
comment. And then Equals Three LLC versus Jukin Media.
Finding transform reviews where host reacted and commented on
original videos. Facts here closely aligned with those in Stebbins
v. Alphabet. In Stebbins, the court found the subject of live
streams to be highly transformative works because the live streams
involved the viewing of the subject video for seconds at a time
before pausing to respond and critique the subject video.
The subject video created by the plaintiff provided the plaintiff's
analysis and opinions regarding a video
The live streams, however, provided commentary on the subject
video as well as several additional hours regarding other videos
produced by the plaintiff and its comments thereon. The The relevant
live stream in Stebbins paused and commented on plaintiff's retrospective
with the purpose of reviewing or mocking the video.
This criticism is the heart of fair use doctrine and it would
lose meaning without reproduction of the plaintiff's video. Yes.
Basically, you can't mock something without actually having the
original work, right? See World Health Organization for the Visual
Arts Inc. versus Goldsmith, noting commentary or criticism that
targets an original work may have compelling reason to counteract
the original by borrowing from it. As in Stebbins, defendant's
live stream provided commentary on The Nuke and the sharp and
sharp criticism of the claims made within the documentary. Throughout
the live stream, defendant often paused The Nuke to offer spontaneous
reactions, engaged with their audience through a live chat, and
provided real-time commentary interspersed with tangential
Wow, let's go.
Because defendant's use of copyrighted materials served a completely
different function than that of the plaintiffs, this first factor
weighs in defendant's favor. The difference in viewing experiences
here is is undisputed. Indeed, plaintiff states where the Nuke
seeks to expose
We're going to We're going to cite the complaint for this as
well. Very cool.
Where the Nuke seeks to expose how Paik radicalizes people online
to be anti-Semitic and anti-Israel, Denims attempts to use the
Nuke for the exact opposite purpose, to radicalize her audience
to be anti-Semitic and anti-Israel along with defending Hassan.
Let's go. Thank you, Ethan Klein. W Ethan Klein.
In opposition, plaintiff presents unsuccessful arguments. See
generally the opposition. First, plaintiff cites Defont DeFontbrune
versus Woolsley, 9th Circuit 2022 for the for the proposition
that the purposes of plaintiff's video and defendant's livestream
overlap to undermine defendant's transformative argument. Here,
plaintiff has conceded that the purposes of both videos do not
overlap by stating
the exact thing. So, the argument you made undermined by your
own argument in the initial complaint. Very cool. Oh
Additionally, the two subject videos are disparate from the subject
works in DeFontbrune, which did overlap in nature. In DeFontbrune,
the Picasso project and the subject photographs both presented
the works of Picasso with the shared purpose of documenting Picasso's
As previously established, the subject videos in this matter
do not share such an overlapping purpose. Second, plaintiff cites
Monge v. Mayamag, Inc., 9th Circuit 2012 for the proposition
that defendant engaged in wholesale copying sprinkled with spoken
commentary, which the court in Monge found at best minimally
transformative.
Defendant's livestream went beyond merely reproducing or supplanting
the Nuke, however. Rather, as set forth above, the livestream
incorporated real-time commentary, criticism, and analysis that
altered the purpose and character of the original work. He really
himself entirely on the first On the first leg, he just totally
himself.
Accordingly, unlike the defendant in defendant did not simply
repackage or republish the underlying work with the incidental
commentary, but instead used the work in furtherance of a distinct
expressive purpose. For the foregoing reasons, the court finds
the use to be
Let's go.
Anyway, the third statutory factor asks whether the amount and
substantiality of the portion used in relation to the copyrighted
work as a whole favors fair use. 17 U.S.C. Section 103
The third factor looks to the qualitative amount and qualitative
value of the original work used in relation to the justification
for that use.
And then they're setting the Hoss case again, noting the third
factor considers the proportion of the copyrighted work used
and then how well tailored that use was to the allegedly infringing
works pri- proper purpose, no matter how large or long the alleged
infringing work is.
The law is clear, however, this is setting Hoss again. The law
is clear, however, the quantity alone is not
This factor circles back to the first factor because the extent
of permissi- permissible copying varies with the purpose and
character of THE USE. OH,
IT'S FUNNY HOW IT'S like it really just all comes back to how
transformative it And Ethan Klein gave it away
in his filings, right?
Like it all circles back to, well, if it's maximally transformative,
then you can kind of copy the whole thing. And they seeded that
it was maximally transformative. I'm interested to see how Ethan
can try to spin losing this, but winning on a countdown stream
as being some principled position and not just to hurt his enemy.
He can't He can't He is just a spineless
Now, if he continues, he is a spineless
Running on just this stream alone is embarrassing, man.
The court has found that copying another work in its entirety
is not dispositive as to infringement if the neces- if necessary
for its intended transformative use. See again, Ethan Klein's
case against Matt Hoss. A great deal of plaintiff's work has
was copied, but such copying was plainly necessary to you to
the commentary and critique. And then they got the Stebbins case
as well. Even if the court were to credit plaintiff's claim,
that that Kreetosis copied the entirety of the retrospective,
that would not be dispositive. Kreetosis used the retrospective
clips in order to further the live stream's transformative purpose
of critical commentary.
Bro, they are quite literally saying snarking is your right.
SNARKING IS LEGAL. SNARKING IS LEGAL!
It's true. Many people are saying this. Snarking has been declared
legal.
Here, defendant showed the entirety or nearly the entirety of
the nuke. Complaint paragraph two. It is evident that to comment
on the on and critique a work, clips of the original may be used.
They cite their own case again. Parody must be able to conjure
up at least enough of the original to make the object of its
critical wit recognizable. Copying does not become excessive
in relation to the parodic purpose merely because the portion
taken was the original's heart.
The court in Hustler Day recognized that without using actual
clips, the commentary and critique here would lose context and
utility.
Here, the extent and quality and and importance of the video
clips used by defendant was reasonable to accomplish the transformative
purpose of critical commentary. Accordingly, the court finds
this factor does not weigh against the
Oh, it's interesting.
So, basically, one factor weighs against the defendant, another
factor weighs in favor of defendant. Transformative, it's transformative.
The nature of the work weighs against the defendant, right? Weighs
against the finding of fair use.
But this is not terribly important, okay? And then factor three,
it actually doesn't weigh, it's basically neutral then, right?
So, now factor four. This is going to be good. We'll have to
see how this I don't know how this goes cuz I do think there's
a real argument that the markets are totally diverging, that
there would be no way. And I think Ethan Klein gives this away
in his own arguments as pointed out by Denim's attorneys, Okay?
The fourth factor asks what effect the allegedly infringed infringing
use has on the potential market for or value of the copyrighted
work. 17 U.S.C. Section
This factor considers the extent of market harm caused by the
particular actions of the alleged infringer, but also whether
the unrestricted and widespread conduct of the sort engaged in
by the defendant would result in a substantially adverse impact
on the potential market for the original. Campbell 510 U.S. at
590, where the where the allegedly infringing use does not substitute
for the original and serves a different market function. And
again,
Ethan Klein sort of argued the snarkers would never watch his
stuff and that was like their whole purpose. And so there is
essentially no way that he could argue the people watching who
were seeking Denham's out explicitly to avoid him are a market
he should have access to or market he does have access to.
Such factors weighs in favor of fair
In Campbell, the court found that when a true use is transformative,
market substitution is at least less certain and market harm
may not be so readily inferred. Indeed, as to parody pure and
simple, it is more likely that the new work will not affect the
market for the original in a way that in a way cognizable under
this factor, that is, by acting as a substitute for it. Okay.
So, the more transformative it is, the less idea that it's certain
that there would be a market harm, even if you're like making
a bunch of money. As to parody pure and simple, it is more likely
that the new work will not affect the market for the original
in a way cognizable under this factor, that is, by acting as
a substitute for it. Thus, where the original work and new work
serve different market functions, such that there is no market
substitution, the new work is more likely to be fair use. Defendant's
livestream is not a market substitute for the nuke because someone
watching the former will have a very different experience from
watching the latter. And again, we're citing Matt Hoss significantly
the Matt Hoss Hoss case significantly here. Hossen Sadegh versus
Klein, 276 F. Supplemental at 47.
Anyone seeking to watch The Nuke, a scripted and edited documentary,
would have a distinctly different experience watching defendant's
fragmented, start-and-stop livestream, which featured spontaneous
reaction, live chat interaction, sharp criticism throughout,
and extrinsic source material.
Oh, I feel like the impression I'm getting now is not only is
snarking a human right, snarking is the way to get great right?
If you are ready to snark, then the world is your oyster, okay?
If you're ready to snark,
then you can transform anything. You are You are
You have infinite powers as a snarker, right? That if you're
if you're willing to go and your whole purpose is to snark
then all work you do is transformative, okay? All snarking is
transformative by
If my goal by what in watching your content is to snark you,
then it will naturally be
It will be to counter your purpose.
Finding a lack of market substitution because anyone seeking
to watch the livestreams would have a fundamentally different
viewing experience than a person seeking to watch the
Then Matt Hoss again, anyone seeking to enjoy the original on
its own will have a very different experience watching the reaction
video. Finding no market harm where a person could not use the
allegedly infringing work, a thumbnail photograph, as a substitute
for the copyright high-resolution photograph. Indeed, plaintiff's
own allegation suggests as much. Denim's attempts to use The
Nuke for the exact opposite
And again, we cited this again. Bro, this actually nuked him
completely. His own lawyers nuked him. Dude, what did I say?
I feel like I said it's so funny that Ethan Klein's own lawyers
like might have blown up his case, and they completely blew up
his case. Like they obliterated his case. His own lawyers. The
decision in Hughes v. Benjamin 473 blah blah blah blah blah is
highly instructive. There the court held, "Here, there is no
danger that SJW levels of awareness will usurp the market of
progressive commentary such as We Thought She Would Win. Benjamin's
target audience, generally political conservatives and libertarians,
is obviously not the same as Huse's target audience, generally
political liberals. Moreover, through SJW levels of
or sorry, the although SJW levels of awareness is comprised entirely
of portions of We Thought She Would Win, there is no reason to
think that Huse's audience will abandon her progressive YouTube
channel to watch the derisively titled SJW levels of awareness
on a conservative YouTube channel simply because it contains
parts of her work.
So, again, the political aspect comes in here, right? Like, obviously,
these are different audiences. Obviously, these people are like
enemies. Nobody who's watching through Denims like likes Ethan
Klein. This is actually kind of huge for react content. Denims
is By the way, Denims could have rolled over and settled this,
but Denims has struck a blow for snarkers everywhere and reactors
everywhere. Denims is the person defending us. Thank god for
I'll put this back on screen. Thank you, Denims. Thank you. Thank
you. The queen of fair use.
Accordingly, the court finds that defendant's livestream is not
a market substitute for the nuke.
Boom. Not a market substitute. Now, very interestingly here,
I'm going to point it out for Pisco cuz I I don't know if Pisco's
ever watching, okay? But, just for Pisco's sake, I'll point out,
where did they go? Did the Did the judge at any point go, "Well,
but we would want to say it's not a market substitute, but she
said she wanted to make a market substitute, so we're going to
make it It's actually market No. Not even mentioned cuz nobody
cares cuz you were all wrong. Every single person who thought
that made a big difference, you were wrong.
Suck it.
So, we're right here at the end because three of the four fair
use factors strongly favor defendant, including the most important
factor, the purpose and character of the use, the court concludes
that the fair use defense applies as a matter of law. Thus, defendant's
motion for judgment on the proceedings or on the pleadings, rather,
is granted.
Conclusion: For the foregoing reasons, the court grants defendant's
motion for judgment on the pleadings. The court orders defendant
to prepare a and submit a proposed judgment in this matter within
7 days of this order. It is so ordered.
Now,
one thing we do have to keep in mind is this is a this is a tentative
order, okay? So, technically, tomorrow Ethan is going to get
a chance to go and argue against this, but I don't understand
he's going to have to argue basically, unless he gets a mulligan,
I don't know how he argues against this. It's like over.
>> Dude, we got to we got to keep it going. We got to keep
it pushing. Well, this is Ethan Klein's reaction to this information.
>> from witnesses, most of who were in hiding and heard
or saw it happen.
>> Did you not hear what they said? >> First of all,
she's a
Shame on you. >> What? You. How dare you? >> This
guy's a piece of [__] This guy's Someone's got to
take this guy down a >> she is a
That's a of a person.
>> Okay. So, I What a monster. What a monster. Then I see
Denims with that stupid smile and I'm like,
>> She is earning the coveted distinction of being a
I have I have decreed, [laughter] let it be known that Denims
is a dumb
I know I should apologize once again to uh Denims, the dumb
that I hate. >> Jesus, man. >> Just because I was
wrong about her sleeping with um Destiny. I spoke out of turn
there and I apologize for that. Even though I despise her.
We got updates from the Nicholas DeOrio Discord in real time.
Let's go. Crazy each each day updates. Denims won here. Defend
her defense judgment. Ethan can still appeal this decision and
she's still being sued for her reaction to the countdown stream,
but for the content nuke, the judge ruled in her favor. I'll
be honest, I read through their examples of fair use and if they
stick this stick to this, then everyone can fully restream anyone's
content as long as they disagree in some way at least once every
10 minutes, then you're fair use even if you add nothing.
Uh no, I'm going to say the political nature of this actually
it doesn't get referenced, but the political nature of this actually
makes a huge difference as well, okay? But also snarking is legal
as judged by some California courts,
Hell yeah, dude. I could be a chair streamer. Ethan will take
it to appeals and have it crushed there to be honest. Maybe Goeast
is onto something with these woke liberal judges.
Dude, uh come on, man.
I'll be honest, I read through their example blah blah blah blah
blah. This is such a [__] sad judgment. THIS DECISION
TOTALLY SCREWS THE START case if it doesn't go to appeal. Like
they wasted time on more motions when they had to wait one day
for Denim's to win.
Wait. Yeah.
Wait, why are they acting like that's a bad thing? Oh, cuz it's
Diorio's Discord. Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, I got it. I got
it.
I agree, but it's really surprising because the other judge ruled
it to be a hate watch party and usually judges don't disagree
with each other.
What? A hate watch party?
Wait, was that without any evidence?
Was the stream like looked at? What is this? What do you mean
the judge ruled it to be a hate watch party?
Throw back to when Peisko initially criticized the the filing.
Bigger >> The notion that and this is not even disputable
at this point that H3 is acting like a savior for the fair use
community, the reaction community is so
as to be insulting to my intelligence.
and I believe it actually is a bit of disingenuousness to start
off with this broader concern about the quote injustice regarding
these kinds of streams that basically steal content and don't
transform the nature of the content at all or provide any commentary.
To start with that view, to show XQC be one of the prime suspects,
one of the biggest perveyors, and then to try to distinguish
and say this is really about helping the reaction community to
prevent a kind of a lawsuit from Disney or Sony. That is so disingenuous
and it's just false. It doesn't pass the smell test at all. I
resent it. And then second point, the complaint's unhinged. You
have a strong case, just present the case. Don't be a loser idiot.
Hire some lawyer who either doesn't know what he's doing or
you're telling him to do this kind of
It's sloppy, tons of typos, formatting errors. It's impossible
to read. It's [__] So, if you really cared about
protecting the reaction community, you wouldn't use that filing,
dude.
>> This guy says there are two complaints and that this
isn't a big deal. Well, the other complaint is for something
that's total The other complaint is for the stream, the countdown
stream, that they registered after the fact cuz they knew they
couldn't get Denholm's. They knew it might be more difficult
to get Denholm's on the nuke. But, all of their videos, all of
the propaganda they've been putting out into the world, has been
entirely about the nuke. Every principal position they took is
about the nuke. They look like total
morons. They look like total They look totally spiteful if they
continue on with just the stream.
It's It would be crazy. They look They look like total losers.
But, really, Ethan Klein, we've seen a lot of evidence that Ethan
Klein doesn't mind looking like a complete loser, right? In fact,
Ethan Klein kind of relishes in looking like a complete loser.
So, probably will probably will continue on that same
>> Filled with venom, filled with, you know, not getting
into the facts, not getting into the point. This was a hit piece
in the form of a legal filing. And maybe if it's even true on
some base accusations. But don't pretend you're here for the
broader reaction community when you file that piece of [__]
You're not doing anyone any help. >> You don't think anyone
would settle with a simple public apology? >> Of what?
I'm sorry for what? That's the question, right? And it's the
it's a great question, right? What is what are they sorry for?
What does Ethan want them to be sorry [laughter] for? He doesn't
want them to be sorry for Thank you for the
He doesn't want them to be sorry for copyright infringement.
That's not what's going on here. And you have to >> By
the way, disagreeing with Pisco, all of the people who disagreed
with Pisco cuz they got their feefees hurt, you are diverging
from reality. I hope this signal is helpful to you. You are diverging
from reality. There are people who are warping your perception
of the world, okay, in a way that's going to prevent you from
being able to interact with it effectively. Pisco didn't make
arguments cuz he really loves Ethan Klein or really hates Ethan
Klein. He made arguments based on the facts. Once Ethan Klein
came out and his lawyers made about how Denim's work was like
perfectly transformative, Pisco
he he basically went on the content dude like this is actually
going to be a problem now.
I don't know if anybody else did that. >> To be very like
naive to think that that's what they would want apology for.
I'm sorry for stealing your video. XQC stole your video. He's
not actually mad about that. He's mad about
these people
because of who they are. Not what they
Or what they did on other stuff, not this. That's it.
>> That's it. That's obviously just it. Hold on, I've got
a a scroll from Nicholas Yorio's Discord. Give me a
The decision totally screws the Snark case if it doesn't go to
appeal. It doesn't. She's still being sued two times. If they
get her for the countdown stream, it'll still it would still
work for Snark.
Did the Snarkers link to her for the countdown stream or just
for the nuke? I I the Snarkers might have a case to dismiss if
it's not related to the nuke, right? That's what they were all
talking about. I don't know if they were trying to send people
to her for the countdown stream. Is the contributory charge for
the countdown? I thought it was just for the nuke. Dude, every
copyright holder in the country is going to have their eyes on
this case now. Snarkers in all four case. Well, two of them got
settled and then I guess there's two cases against Denims. And
I don't understand what the Snarkers were doing on the other
one.
I don't think the Snarkers linked to the countdown stream. Okay,
well.
I have a hard time believing the judge would go this way if she
was sued for watching a theatrical movie. Like a thing that costs
money, a thing that's paywalled? Yeah, I probably wouldn't. Would
probably go like way differently actually.
Don't try to Don't try to apply paywalled content to this. That's
not what's going on here. Disney, Netflix, all of them. This
is a insane judgment.
The main thing I see is it's because she was against the content
she reacted to, like critical.
Every anti-woke creator gets a free pass to watch watch party
every Disney movie. No, it's basically The question is, how likely
is it that somebody would watch your video over the original
video? If you have The Critical Drinker putting up like a $30
ticket mis- Disney movie in his video, or a $30 DVD, or $30 like
pay-to-watch on Amazon video in his own YouTube video and publishing
it there, obviously that's market replacement. Obviously people
will deal with a total commenting so that they can go and watch
the video, right?
But nobody is doing that for Denims. Nobody is going to watch
Denims when on the same platforms they can go and watch
It is totally different. Do you seriously think if a judge saw
the countdown stream and realized it's literally a clock counting
down and nothing else, they'd take it seriously as as theft of
copyright? Well, I don't think the copyright the countdown stream
is only that. I do think there's a clip of Denims getting up
and walking away while the H3 crew are talking.
I think I don't think it's just a countdown only. I think they're
doing a countdown, but they were also talking and stuff.
Now, that's a live stream on a live stream. That's way different.
That is not like a creative work in the same way. I think live
streamers always go and watch each other. I don't think that's
quite the same thing, to be honest with you. Now, would it be
fair use? I don't know, but it feels like for it to be adjudicated
under copyright is it's crazy to me. Like, if that were the case,
I can go back and
anytime Stardust has ever reacted to me, I surely certainly could
sue her on that same thing, right?
But, I'm truly shocked if she wins react is dead or react react
gate is dead and excuse me, he was right. I think it basically
is asking for a big media company to come after them if this
goes through. No, it's not.
Surprise, surprise, every Ethan Klein detractor will celebrate.
Not because they care about fair use or whatever, but because
they hate Ethan Klein.
I care about fair use and I hate ETHAN KLEIN. DUBS ALL AROUND,
BOYS. LET'S GO. As somebody who cares about fair use and hates
Ethan Klein at the same time, today's basically Christmas.
Is it not? I I I think today's just Christmas, man. It's awesome.
I mean, it would be a a win for them. Snarkers need a win. It's
been rough for them. Meant snarker, but snakes works, too. Oh,
snakes need a win. It's been rough for them. Meant snarker, but
snakes work, too. The total difference between this and the snark
motion is so interesting. This judgment would make it unprofitable
to ever make content for yourself again, so long as someone can
just be critical of it.
Snarking is a human right. Snarking is legal. Snarking is is
in fact encouraged by copyright.
Yes, by sorry, the fair use doctrine. Snarking is awesome. Legal
lawyer versus Denim's super expensive lawyer team.
I don't remember Denim's reaction, but wasn't it her calling
Ethan dumb and saying he doesn't know what he's talking about?
Awesome.
Imagine if she'd been calling him like
like neurotic.
Histrionic the whole time. Imagine if she'd been throwing words
out like that, that would have been even better. Darking will
be added to the United Nations Charter in 2026. It will.
It will, won't it?
Well, cope aside, this is a total Denim's victory. We'll see
if Ethan goes for an appeal and what will happen there. I do
not expect this stand to stand very long. There's just genuinely
no way. I want to believe a judge wouldn't make this ruling for
no reason. We'll see though. I think the fair use argument is
fine enough if the logic is she met the bare minimum. But I personally
think the market replacement was a significant deal. No, you
don't understand. With this, the only type of copyright protection
you will have then is full re-uploads and anyone who agrees with
you I I brought or anyone who agrees with you ironically. This
opens hostile use of your copyrighted material for total public
use. No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. Now, in some cases that
will be the case. But realistically,
Ethan Klein didn't even try to challenge on transformative on
transformativity. He didn't try to argue it. He gave it away.
Reactions from the drillers that the H3 saw, oh boy. Oh boy.
Tentative ruling on Tenured Entertainment versus Denim's, motion
for judgment on proceedings granted.
Not so great news, basically Denim's won pending the actual hearing
tomorrow. So, they ruled against Ethan because of the precedent
set in the Matt Hoss lawsuit?
Uh yeah. Uh problem?
Friendly reminder, this is one of two complaints, not the entire
case. What's the other complaint? She sued for a reaction to
the nuke itself and the countdown to the nuke, both of which
were registered. Both sides agreed to have to Both sides agreed
to give this motion a shot to see how it goes. Her reaction to
the countdown was drastically different. Her total time reacting
to the countdown was less than 20% of the total run time, where
her nuke reaction was almost 2x I believe, and is the motion
slash ruling based on her react to the countdown or to the The
nuke itself. Nuke Denim's might sneak this out because the strongest
argument Ethan has to the nuke is the last thing that she said
No, this isn't. No, this isn't even It's not even not don't even
take it into account, man. Come on, man.
Sorry, we're not done with Nicholas Geragos discord. We're going
to get one pot out of the way before we go to the next pot, okay?
Just chill. I'm chilling. I'm chilling. I'm chilling. Yeah. Yeah,
it's a very very low bar going by this. Well, the argument is
being openly hostile in itself is transformative. Yeah? A little
bit. A little bit. A little bit. Not only does this run counter
to pretty much every legal scholar I've ever seen on the topic,
but of the reason for
No, it doesn't. Also, Dennis literally said in plain English
that she was being a market replacement stealing from Ethan Klein
AND THEN JUSTIFIED STEALING. BY the way, Becket, this is one
of your This is one of your Becket, I see that tag, Becket.
Becket, somebody get Becket on the line.
This is one of yours. Deal with it, okay? Might as well not have
copyright.
Like, could you sit there silently with a sign pointed at the
movie that just said, "This sucks." and would that count because
it's continuous hostile
This This Look, there's people agreeing. No, it wouldn't. Obviously,
it wouldn't.
You might as well not have a copyright unless you're Disney or
Hollywood. If you're not, you're fair game.
I'm super interested in the snark element now. Let's assume there's
no appeal and this is the final decision. If Frogan defaults,
then does that make the snarkers officially liable for contributory
infringement? And if they are, does the subpoena not even matter
because matter and Ethan has to get their names to sue them that
way? Or does she actually need to defend herself for that to
happen? She's still being sued for the countdown stream. So,
let's say Ethan takes a loss of the content nuke. She will still
need to defend herself for the one for that one. And if she's
found not to to be not guilty of copyright infringement both
cases, then yeah, snark is free for her. But if they promoted
Frogan or Casey, who have both lost, then Ethan can still get
them for contributing to copyright infringement in my understanding.
Regardless, this is kind of a catastrophic loss for Ethan barring
a win on appeal. Yes and no. I'm confident he win the countdown
stream and I know he wanted to win on the nuke, so people shut
up.
the countdown stream is just total cope. I mean, we pointed this
out from the very beginning that the countdown stream is registered
after because he wants to hurt these people. He doesn't want
to win on the idea. The countdown stream is not a creative work.
The countdown stream is well, I mean, it's a creative work in
that it's like it's a stream. Like I I don't think it's the same.
It's not like the edited skits. It's not none of the curated
points. It's none of the pre-edited anything, right? It's just
them before they play the video.
Uh absolutely, the anti-H3 crowd try their best to ignore the
fact that Denims also rebroadcast the H3 podcast live stream
while waiting for the No, we all point out that this is totally
to sue for this. That he obviously registered it way after the
fact, after she had already reacted to it, by the way. I believe
that's the case, right? I believe the stream happens in February
at some point. No, no, no.
Oh, hold on. When does he register it? I think he registers to
Yeah, he has to register it after cuz obviously she has to react
to it.
I think he registers it after the stream, right?
Stream January 28th, 9th, registered March 31st. Yes. Yeah, this
[__] This
[__] meaning Ethan Klein, not Denims in this case.
What a loser.
What a loser, man.
This guy's a total loser.
All right. We keep going. We keep it pushing.
Turns out it's Yes, but the tentative ruling itself reads pretty
clear. But I don't see this judge changing their mind
I haven't read it, but I always thought that the the Denims case
was weak. Wouldn't be surprised me if he lost. Their Their choice
of proof of fair use is so bizarre to me. It's literally only
because she insulted that it seems to be fair use. No, it's that
the character of the of the use, the transformativity of the
as stated by Ethan Klein's own team, is maximal. The strongest
element in her case was always market replacement. No, it wasn't.
No, it it never was. This is total total cope. This was never
a strong element. In fact, it's not even referenced and she lost
or sorry, and Ethan lost on this element.
Ethan literally lost on this. This is a a total content creator
told you this and you believed it because you are yourself cattle.
Worthless cattle. That is why you believed it. You didn't look
into it. You didn't care to hear of the other side of it. You
are just cattle who hoped that it was true.
Criticism is a component of fair use, but you you would assume
substance criticism. Like you're one second. The strongest element
in this case is always this. So, that was one quarter. She That
was the one quarter she didn't prevail on so far. No, that's
not true. He literally prevailed on it. She literally prevailed
on it. I believe I was told that Denims was being sued for over
a stream that was most likely fair use, but then another that
likely wasn't and was a market replacement. Is this No. No. I
don't think that was the narrative that was going around. Right?
I think a lot of Well, I mean, I I thought she was dead to rights
on the content nuke because she got up and walked away. That's
the problem, right?
I think everybody in the H3 universe absolutely was saying that
that Denims was dead to rights on the content nuke. Not just
not
not just the stream, but the content nuke. She was dead to rights
because it wasn't transformative. I would like to know who Alex
was told this by. I don't know what he means I was told by, but
Good stuff. Good stuff. Good stuff. I I feel like if he's listening
to what cuz even Pisco thought she would probably still lose
in the content nuke.
Right? The cope is building in Yeat's post, too? Oh.
Get some cope. We got some cope building
Let's go. Let's check it out. Denims tentatively wins content
nuke fair use lawsuit against Ethan Klein. Klein and his counsel
will have an opportunity to argue tomorrow. But, the sex tourist
YouTube lawyer told me Ethan was going to win. How could he possibly
be wrong? This has to BE A BIASED JUDGE.
She literally said multiple times on stream that she was trying
to be a replacement for the content. THAT'S A LEGAL STANDARD
THAT COPYRIGHT law sets.
No, it's not.
L Ethan, L Destiny, L Israel, W Denims, W Hassan, W Palestine.